times may be dark but we are Earth's
greatest hope look around a gathering of
noble guardians new and old okay good
luck
you're a bunch of dirty misfits but
you're all this letter you'll have to do
our home was attacked I would think for
the fifty endless on sir it kept coming
do I get firing not gonna lie I was
magnificent despite the sacrifice of
many Braves on we lost everything the
power the city our home so everything is
gone your stuff
I stopped most importantly my stuff
today's you know how enemy his Mane is
scary or Gil Glen is it I don't know
something with a Jake go I know you look
to me in times of peril
but this is not my battle alone which
means if I don't see you out there I'll
kill you myself
it is time to avenge this injustice but
that is the duty of all guardians
worst-case scenario is I but who knows
maybe you won't know I ask you who will
stand yes
oh really guys that that was inspiring
also there will be a ton of whoo ah yeah
right that's what I thought
[Applause]
pre-order incubator early access
[Music]
[Music]